بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
وصفيه من خلقه وخليله
وامينه على وحيه الداعي الى رضوانه اما
‏place
jeep
with some kindur around the steeringel
pleas
vehicle immedi parked in the parking
spot
are parking spots so there not any need
رمضان
الطيره
الطير
of
a person
tries to extrapolate
bad om
‏from the
environment around him.
So for instance, a person sees a black
cat walk across their path or they see a
bird fly in a certain way or lizard or
anything and it doesn't necessarily have
to be an animal it is well could be
anything.
‏types of
that was used time
wasلام
[Silence]
صلاه
الاستخاره
صلاه الاستخاره
ازلامciones
whatever
you
‏whatever takory
concept
andcept
in this
first introduced
just before
unable to finish
is the narration ofير
this narration
ابو هريره
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
لا عدوى ولا طيره ولا هامه
ولا سفر
صلى الله عليه
‏number
صلى الله عليه وسلم
notev
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لاcase
illness
‏ill can trans from one person to
another oneal to another to hum from hum
to
this is to
now prop
here
is no contagion
‏things are
not
any
kind of
that is contag
understand in immedi
the concept of contag and the concept of
contagion
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏us
understand
we have understand
that what is me is not necessarily that
he is ne
of these things
but instead that he is nef
that people had in time surrounding
these
قران
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولا شفاعه
what
the prop صلى الله عليه
‏will no intercession on the day of judg
no that's not what me not
saying
theev
that ‏around in time peopleah
inter would
inter
other
god would be
this
صلى الله
سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏not that would not any
I want to mention something so we have
20 minut here to sit and listen to the
words of the words of the prop
you have someone thatuded decades to you
this knowledge itutely amazes me that we
can't put our down minut to listen
‏what is going on in your that is
so devating important
that as Allah's words and prophet words
are being spoken they just spill over as
we si through WhatsApp or Instagram or
Tikt or whatever it is that we can't put
it down for 2 minutes. It's fascinating.
‏Is it a drug?
Are we addicted?
Put yourself in my position.
الله
على كل حال
صلى الله عليه وسلم
العدو والطيره
‏some
things have
and some things
of time
people
الله سبحانه وتالى tellsر
يا ايها الذين امنوا انفقوا مما رزقناكم
من قبل ان ياتيكم
من قبل ان ياتي يوم لا بيع فيه ولا خله
ولا شفاعه
‏will interر
ولا يشفعون
الا لمن ارتضى
angg
‏here
any
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
here
is particular type of intercession
when if you to be standing among of
people time
‏and
standing among the time and you
the intercession what a would come into
mind
the intercession of the id
of worers الله ما نعبدهم الا ليقربونا
الى الله زلفا
ويقولون هؤلاء شفعاؤنا عند الله
العزه
منذ
الخلصه
نوح عليه السلامواع
يغوث ان يعوقس
‏gods that they worship these id that
they worship
they didn't worship these idols because
they believe these ids created the
heavens and the earth
they didn't worship these ids because
they believed that these ids could benit
them
har them aside from
they wors because
‏person a sa who is very close to Allah
and if I worship this idol if I sl for
it if I come and show my dev to it that
this sa
will then see my work
he will then allow me into his good
graces and
الله سبحانه وتالى
was
in time of time of people of نوح the
people of the people of all the people
that worship id this is what theyed for
the part and so
the idea
‏is not that there is no inter of any
form f on the day of judg that's not
what the ver mean
the ver means the intercession that
first com mind
with the people of that is what there is
will be none of on the day of judgement
he
وانفقوا مما رزقناكم من قبل ان ياتي يوم
لا بيع فيه ولا خله ولا شفاعه
will love
‏inter
الله
takeر
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏anotherle
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
لم يعمل خير
لم يعمل خيرا قط
ever
life
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا اله الا الله
لم يعمل خيرا
‏particularly
this person
anything
is a person who all time enery focused
on
لم يعمل خيرا قطل
الله عليه وسلمر
الله
جاه
‏that never happen that will not permitt
on the day of judg that is not
and so
this narration
is no different that listen to the way
that he speaks in this narration the
prophet
لا عدوى ولا طيره ولا هامه ولا صفر
are
there is
ham is actually ow very particular
belief that they had at the time and
there is no safar the
لا سفر
يعني شهر سفر
انable
[Silence]
عدed
one person
and another person who does not have
that person
is something
الله سبحانه وى permission
‏medye
viewes
noticion
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم لا
رضي الله عنهم
صلى الله عليه وسلم يا رسول الله ارايت
بعيرا اجرب
ان جعل عل مع سائر الابعره الصحيحه
فانه يعديها بمعنى الحديث في الصحيح
فقال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فمن اعد
الاولى
اها يعني البعير الاول اول واحد نرجع نرجع
نرجع لاول بعير في تاريخ
في تاريخ ال ال ال
الابعره في تاريخ ال البعير الحيوان نفسه
اول بعير اجرب ظهر على العالم من الذي
اعداه
نقول بل هذا كان بامر الله
هل له اسباب حسيه نعم قد يكون له اسباب
حسيه الله خلق السماوات والارض في سته
ايام باسباب حسيه خلق الانسان من نطفه
باسباب حسيه صح ولا لا لكن بامر من
بامر الله
اذا اذا كانت العدوى
خارجه
عن اطار قدر الله وامر الله فمن الذي اعدى
الاولى
ففهم الصحابه ان المقصود ليس نفي العدو
وانما نفي العدوى
بدون امر الله
الواحد لا يمرض الا بامر الله
ولا يشفى الا بامر الله وان يمسسك الله
بضر فلا كاشف له الا هو وان يمسسك بخير
فهو على كل شيء قدير سبحانه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابو حسين ممكن بالله بس تزيح المروحه عشان
لما يطلع الخطيب لا بس حطها ورا عشان
الخطيب ما يقعد يتباطح يتصارع مع المروحه
تصير
تصير مصارعه
وبعدين
عننا خطيب اليوم
[Silence]
‏said
that madeck
that is الله سبحانه وى he not there is
no contagees
he not speaking about that he is
speaking about a contagiouse
that is not to the discretion of even if
you are
if you contract a contagee
is by
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان شاء الله تعالى نسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يعلمنا ما
ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا وان يزيدنا
علما والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
اوكي
بسم الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد
لا
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على
حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل
فلن تجد له وليا مرشدا
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين
اما بعد معاشر الموحدين عباد الله فان
اصدق الكلام كلام الله عز وجل وخير الهدي
هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وان شر
الامور محدثاتها ان كل محدثه بدعه
وان كل بدعه ضلاله وان كل ضلاله في النار
اسال الله العظيم رب العرش العظيم بمنه
وكرمه وعفوه ان يجيرني واياكم منها انه
ولي ذلك والقادر عليه اما بعد يا ايها
الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم
من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث منهما
رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام ان
الله كان عليكم رقيبا يا ايها الذين امنوا
اتقوا الله وقولوا قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم ومن
يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما اما
بعد
لما قال الله سبحانه وتعالى
انما كان قول المؤمنين اذا دعوا الى الله
ورسوله ليحكم بينهم ان يقولوا سمعنا
واطعنا واولئك هم المفلحون
ولما قال سبحانه وتعالى قل اطيعوا الله
واطيعوا الرسول لعلكم ترحمون.
جاءت هذه الايات الكريمه كمنهج في الطاعه
للمؤمنين
كما انها جاءت ايضا ذما ضنيا
للانتقائيه في الدين
فمن غير ادنى شك ان الانتقائيه في الدين
هي من المفسدات العظيمه لدين المرء
والدنياه
والانتقائيه اعني هنا ان ينتقد الانسان
المسلم ما يحلو له ويرفض ما لا يروقه
تبعا لهواه
فهذا ليس من مقتضى الايمان
الحق في شيء انما هو شان المنافقين الذين
لا ياخذون الا ما وافق هواهم وما عارضه
فهو مرفوض فلا وجود للهوى في الدين ولا
وجود للراي في الدين ففي الحديث عن عبد
الله بن عمرو بن العاص رضي الله عنهما قال
قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم لا يؤمن
احدكم حتى يكون تبعا لهواه
لا حتى يكون هواه تبعا لما جئت به لكن
الانتقاء اليوم هو الذي ياتي بعكس مضمون
هذه الايات
وبعكس مضمون الايه الكريمه
التي هي كانت خاصه في النزول وعامه في
الدلاله وما كان لمؤمن ولا مؤمنه اذا قضى
الله ورسوله امرا ان يكون لهم الخيره من
امرهم
فتجد ان احكام الله وامره ونواهيه
تخضع لرغبه الانتقاء
تخضع لهواه ورغبه
ورغبته ونزواته واختياراته
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وى
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وى
‏chilable
you are right and correct to choose from
this is not selectivity
selectivity is going beond the options
and the chicilable
to you and this two actually not only
ر
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
قالوا سمعنا واطعنا
سبحانك
ربنا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏Soes
and other
guiding principle
obedience for believers.
‏But without any doubt nowads that
religious selectivity is one of the most
corrupting habits and acts a Muslim can
take or can do.
And I repeat myself just to be clear me
by selectivity
is mean not to choose from the
matterilable to you and the choices
Allah to you as optional.
‏I me the act of personing
fromingable
thinkingcept
all that as
matter
‏againstle
and such act or
has noationover
to the teachings of Islam or the
requirement the true requirements of
being a Muslim
[Silence]
ولما كانت الطاعه ولما كانت طاعه الله
سبحانه وتعالى هي الاقتداء بالنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم قال الله قل اطيعوا الله
واطيعوا الرسول ولما كانت طاعه الله هي
اتباع النبي والاقتداء به صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال تعالى قل ان كنتم تحبون الله
فاتبعوني يحببكم الله فاتبعوني يحببكم
الله ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم ولما كانت طاعه
الله هي الاستسلام
التام والالتزام باوامره سبحانه وتعالى
ونواهيه من غير زياده او نقصان قال الله
تعالى فلا وربك لا يؤمنون حتى يحكموك فيما
شجر بينهم نفى الله سبحانه وتعالى
نفى الله سبحانه وتعالى الايمان عن الشخص
الانتقائي
فان اعطوا منها رضوا وان لم يعطوا منها
فاذا هم يسخطون نظر الله سبحانه وتعالى
الايمان فلا وربك لا يؤمنون حتى يحكموك
فيما شجر بينهم ثم لا يجدوا في انفسهم
حرجا مما قضيت ويسلم تسليما
الله
take الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
اطيع الله
صلى الله عليه
‏Tak him
for
[Silence]
تحبون الله فاتبعوني يحببكم الله
بعد ان عقد الانسان المسلم بعد ان عقد
الانسان المسلم عقد الايمان مع الله فليس
له هنالك خيارات اي خيار غير الخيارات
التي وفرها الله واباحها اليه ليس هنالك
خيارات للانسان المسلم خارجه عن الخيارات
التي وفرها الله له سبحانه وتعالى واباحها
اليه ليس هنالك خيارات للانس الانسان
المسلم غير الخيار التي التي اباحها الله
سبحانه وتعالى بعد ان اسلم وجهه وقلبه
وحياته لله ليس هنالك خيار اخر للانسان
المسلم خارجه عن خيارات الله سبحانه
وتعالى بعد ان ارتضى بحكم الله واقر
بشريعته
ليس هنالك خيار
للانسان المسلم غير خيار بعد ان راضي ان
يتح تحاكم لكتاب الله وسنه نبيه
ونعيد ونقول اقسم الله سبحانه وتعالى ونفى
الايمان
على كل على عن كل انتقائي
ياخذ ما يشتهي ويترك ما لا يشتهي
ياخذ ما يعجبه ويرفض ما لا يروقه
so يسلم
شعه
صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏again
trying to emphasize on this topic
everyilable
ليقائيه
في الدين فهذا الدين شمولي
لما عاتب الله بني اسرائيل قال افتؤمنون
ببعض الكتاب وتكفرون ببعض فما جزاء من
يفعل ذلك منكم الا خزي في الحياه الدنيا
ويوم القيامه يردون الى اشد العذاب وما
الله بغافل عما تعملون هذا الدين شمولي
اما يؤخذ كله او يضيع كله لما ارسل الله
موسى عليه السلام واتاه الالواح قال قال
خذها بقوه
والقوه هنا ليست القوه الجسديه
القوه هنا هي القوه الشموليه باخذ الدين
والالتزام به باخذ الدين كل ما جاء في
الدين بعزم وجديه وحزم وليست القوه
الجسديه
ر
صلى الله عليه وسلم موسى عليه السلام
الواح فيها هدى ونور
‏estive
taking
some
other
point الله سبحانه وتالىران
افتؤمنون ببعض الكتاب وت تكفرون ببعض فما
جزاء من يفعل ذلك منكم
الله
فما جزاء من يفعل ذلك منكم الا خزي في
الحياه الدنيا
الله سبحانه وتالى
مويه عليه
‏said hold them
with strength
and I just said the strength here is not
the physical strength it's rather taking
a comprehensive when it comes to laws
and rules beingehensive
taking all
race all of
بارك الله لي ولكم في القران العظيم
ونفعني واياكم بهدي سيد المرسلين اقول ما
تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم فاستغفروه
انه الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
السلام على المبعوث رحمه للعالمين اللهم
صل وسلم عليه وعلى اصحابه اجمعين
اللهم في هذا اليوم المبارك نسالك من
الخيرات والبركات والمسرات نسالك يا ربنا
ان تتقبل منا اعمالنا ودعائنا وان تحفظ
علينا ديننا وشريعتنا اللهم احفظ علينا
ديننا وشريعتنا
اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد في الاولين وصل
على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين
وصل على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت وحين اللهم
صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد حتى ترث الارض ومن
عليها وانت خير الوارثين اللهم ارحم ضعفنا
اللهم ارحم ضعفنا واجمع شملنا واجبر كسرنا
ويسر امرنا وفرج همنا واشرح صدورنا ووسع
ارزاقنا واقضي عنا ديننا يا رب العالمين
اللهم تقبل توبتنا واغسل حوبتنا
واجب دعوتنا وثبت حجتنا واهد قلوبنا وسدد
السنتنا واسلل سخيمه قلوبنا يا رب
العالمين اللهم اشف مرضانا ومرضى المسلمين
وارحم موتانا وموتى المسلمين وعاف مبتلانا
ومبتلى المسلمين واجعل لنا بكل دعوه اجابه
وبلغنا رضاك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم اعز
الاسلام والمسلمين واعلي رايتي الحق
والدين المبين اللهم اللهم اصلح احوالنا
واحوال المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم اصلح
احوالنا واحوال المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم
الطف بالمسلمين في كل مكان اللهم ارفع
الظلم عنهم اللهم ارفع الكرب عنهم اللهم
امن خوفهم اللهم كن لهم عونا ومؤيدا
ونصيرا اللهم اجبر كسرهم وارحم شهيده
وتقبل شهيدهم واشفي مرضاهم وارحم ضعفهم
واجبر كسرهم يا رب العالمين اللهم اللهم
اجعل هذا المجتمع سخاء رخاء وسائر بلاد
المسلمين اللهم اجزي والدينا عنا خير
الجزاء اللهم اجزي والدينا عنا خير الجزاء
اللهم اجزي والدينا عنا خير الجزاء اللهم
اجزي سيدنا محمد عنا خير ما جزيت نبيا عن
عن امته اللهم اجز نبينا صلى الله عليه
وسلم خير ما جزيت نبيا عن امته اللهم
احينا على سنته اللهم احينا على سنته
وامتنا على ملته واوردنا حوضه واكتب لنا
شفاعته يا رب العالمين عباد الله ان الله
يامر بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى
وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم
لعلكم تذكرون واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الله اكبر الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الاقيم
واعتدلوا استووا سووا الصف سدوا الخلل
اقيموا صفوفكم
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى
فجعله بثا
ان احوى
سنقرئك فلا تنسى
الا ما شاء الله
انه
يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر
ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
من يخشى ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النور الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى
صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
[Arabic recitation]
عامله
ناصبه
تصلى نارا حاميه تسقى من عينيه
ليس لهم طعام الا
ضريع
لا يسمن ولا يغني من جوع
وجوه يومئذ
ناعمه لسعيها راضيه في جنه
عاليه لا تسمع فيها لاغيه فيها عين
جاريه
فيها سرر
مرفوعه
واكواب
موضوعه
ونمارق مصفوفه
وزرابي
مبثوثه
افلا ينظرون
الى الابل كيف خلقت
والى السماء
كيف رفعت والى الجبال كيف صبت والى الارض
كيف سطحت
فذكر انما
انت مذكر
لست عليهم بمسيطر
الا من
تولى وكفر فيعذبه الله العذاب الاكبر
ان الينا
ايابهم
ثم
ان
علينا حسابهم
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
سبحان
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏any question youஹஸ்டேட
கட்அள
அcty
usendo
so has not been as
expect ‏So again it's not the money that
you going get to keep any so this is the
money and the explanation is there on
the screen and the f and standing Не.